let's jump to our first story from not
the bee oh
14 gop senators
just voted to limit your right to keep
and bear arms including lindsey graham
who said he would vigorously oppose the
bill
well if you trust lindsey graham you've
got other issues going on okay
so that's basically the story uh the
senate on tuesday broke through nearly
30 years of stalemate on gun control
legislation by voting 64 to 34 to
advance an 80-page gun safety bill to
respond to the mass shootings of buffalo
and ivaldi that left 31 people dead the
senate voted to proceed to the bill just
more than an hour after negotiators
unveiled its text giving lawmakers
little time to digest its details
so
the bill is actually quite absurd i'm i
was reading that uh it doesn't mention
guns until like page 25.
it's mostly like a whole bunch of weird
medicaid
bloat that they couldn't get through
anywhere else and they were like uh gun
control and they just jammed a bunch of
trash into it but uh yeah the bill is
actually really bad
you've got the republican senator from
west virginia shelley moore capito who's
voting in favor of it which is nuts but
surprise surprise the gop is selling you
out
there's crisis intervention not red flag
laws
crisis intervention which is literally
the same thing
they want a 10-day waiting period and
juvenile check for all background checks
for anyone under 21 which basically
means from 18 to 21 as a legal adult you
will have basic what like a 10 day
waiting period which is what they've
been trying to do for a long time
i'm not gonna sit here and say that
they're trying to ban guns out right but
this is the game they play
they introduce a crazy bill and say we
want to ban weapons we want to raise the
the age to 21. everyone loses their mind
and they go okay okay fine
just enhanced background checks for
people over 18 but under 21. that's
acceptable right and magnitude is like
no what's acceptable would be the
republicans
change what they did i think it was
pennsylvania they took the bill and they
just erased all the texts and put in
constitutional carry instead how about
that how about the republicans actually
stand up for our right to keep and bear
arms but um
makes me wonder like if uh a sh a
shooter appears that has an illegally
acquired gun and and does a mass
shooting like are they gonna then
try and make it harder for people to get
weapons again like this is complete
insanity yeah exactly i mean look there
are so many laws on the books that would
have prevented virtually all of the mass
shootings that have become big news
stories but that hasn't prevented them
from trying to solve the problem by
introducing more laws to go back to your
point tim i disagree i mean i do think
they're trying to ban all guns i think
they know that change occurs
incrementally and every time you point
out okay yeah yeah and so every time you
point out that you know that they go
that's the slippery slope fallacy which
is not of course as we have seen not a
fallacy the slippery slope fallacy is a
fallacy if you're saying you should only
be against this
because it could lead to other things
but if you're able to explain why it
will based on a pattern we've seen in
the past of
incremental change constantly occurring
where the left says it won't then that's
not fallacious that's just pattern
recognition
yep
yeah all right so we all agree that i
think that's a round of applause good
show time for the after show let's get
dirty
you're right sheamus about i mean hitler
did it slowly it took him 10 years oh
about 19 i think they got started in not
29 33 really when hitler got the uh what
they call it the uh what was that act
that he signed that basically stripped
everybody's rights away the enabling act
yeah yeah they burned the reichstag
somebody burned it he blamed the
communists
and then research has been done on this
and they said no there's no way someone
could these two guys that hitler blamed
or this one guy could have burned that
building the way it burned they tried to
replicate it they're like no no this was
like a they think it was a staged
planned event probably by hitler to
scare everyone in the country and then
do the the enabling and seize their
weapons so i'm quite pissed off at these
republicans yeah and one of the
republicans that supported this was uh
shelley moore capito of west virginia
and i'm kind of pissed because we're
currently building our new west virginia
headquarters and i was like this is a
state it's a great state to invest in to
bring our our business which is you know
going to bring a lot of jobs and we're
expanding all thanks to all of you as
members at timcast.com
and now i have to deal with the
republican senator selling me out yo i'm
trying to move my business here they
really don't want it i'll tell you this
maryland hates us
and i don't mean as in like me
personally i mean maryland hates
business
like they have laws that are just like
we will flog you for being a business
it's so insane to start even a charity
in maryland's ridiculous costs yeah like
get your act together you guys do you
not want me to start a business here
they don't new jersey was the same way
it's like i would like to start a
business and bring you know wealth they
would be like we're going to beach over
that instead
so we leave new jersey we we have uh
you know a part of our operation in
maryland and now going through just the
logistics of operating in maryland i'm
just like
it would it is better for the business
to shut everything down and and spend
like a million bucks to just move
everything out of maryland because it is
so hostile to business but now i got to
contend with this shelly moore capital
woman so i was just like okay i need to
confer with my lawyer as to how much
money i'm allowed to spend to make sure
she never wins re-election again and i'm
really pissed off about this perhaps the
only thing these people respond to are
leftist tactics like organizing 24 7
protests outside their homes or putting
up billboards all over their hometown
insulting them and and dragging their
character i'm sick of these people
they're scumbags and the problem is
conservatives there's too many too many
conservatives or cowards don't do
anything and that's why they do it these
gop members know that they can support
the democrats and republicans will
grumble and forget about it so i'm not
i'm not a republican i'm not a
conservative i'm more libertarian than
anything and i'm right pissed off that
this woman in the second most trump
supporting state just sold me out how
dare you madam i don't think i am gonna
put whatever i can to whatever legal
extent to make sure you are retired by
your re-election and you the problem is
she knows it her re-election is until
2026. she's old she's by like well i'll
burn down the house because i'm leaving
anyway these people are absolute
scumbags corning as well well we're
going to negotiate on it's not really
red flag laws literally red flag laws
she puts out a statement she's like we
will never have red flag laws in these
states so you're just enacting a federal
legislation to expand red flag laws but
hoping it doesn't come to west virginia
you absolute scumbag well and also this
idea of negotiating right i mentioned
this on the show the other day they'll
talk about compromise it's not
compromise if you don't get anything out
of it it's not a negotiation if there's
no need for you to be having a
conversation with the person we've seen
the polling data we can't predict the
future but it's probably likely that
republicans are going to do pretty well
in the midterms so you'd think they'd be
able to look down the line and say we
have a little bit of leverage to not
have to cave into the left every single
time they demand something of us but you
know they're going to win the midterms
and everyone's going to clap and cheer
and then they're going to be like and
now what were you trying to pass
democrats
exactly now that we've won and don't
need to argue with you why don't you
move to florida coming to florida ah you
know
west virginia is not all bad just
because this the center did one bad
thing rhonda santa's is pretty great but
uh oh the weather
it's more expensive
so west virginia is still a great place
uh for for expanding a business
land is cheap
much less regulation
uh you guys don't have constitutional
carry yet but i believe it's coming the
gun laws are still not that bad but you
know i lived in florida man and you
can't go out well i lived in miami for
for a year and you just can't go outside
yeah with a beanie yeah there are little
[ __ ] on the side no ian you can't go
outside at all
hey man i'm with you i was in the way i
was in february
99 degrees in february you can go
outside january and february the windows
on every building are drenched yeah our
ac overloaded and started getting all
this condensation because i had cracked
a window and the entire it like flooded
the ceiling it was they have a statue of
the man who invented air conditioning in
miami
i'm not kidding
they literally they warned us not to
open so uh i'll say this
you know i'm trying to think of like
what i can do
and i was thinking like maybe we can
start start a porta potty company and
call them shelly crappitos oh yeah or
maybe like shelley shelly capital boxes
and um i wonder if there's like a legal
issue of me doing that i i tweeted like
can i open a restaurant in charleston
west virginia which is the biggest city
it's only 50 000 people and then name
the
shelley moore capito is trash
i'm i'm wondering i'm going to look into
how much it'll cost to buy every
billboard in that town
and put just putting up i'm not even
talking political ads just character ads
like you're you're a bad person you're
scum you know
and just leaving and just buying them
indefinitely and i'm like it's good
marketing because people are going to be
like why are these ads here oh yeah tim
pool's really pissed off about this make
sure everybody knows how pissed off i am
look
i i am i i said that i'll put a sticky
note on my monitor
and i will say every i'll put it this
way
you know we have sponsors who who pay
good money for us to read out their ads
and all that i wonder what the what the
total monetary value of me ragging on
her would be if every single night i
said never forget she's a scumbag i
think when you said earlier about
organizing and getting people to to
rally obviously you don't want people to
go to people's houses and that's that's
not the but you can organize people to
call at 2pm on a day you make a video in
the morning and you tell people at 3 p.m
you call this number this office and
tell her that you want
whatever that you want her to reverse
her position on this and when she gets
780 calls a day for five days in a row
she will change her position yeah why do
you why do you have to do that why why
is her position this position like where
did the pressure come from
you know what i think it is she's not up
for reelection until 2026 she's probably
going to retire i don't know she's going
to be 60s or something or i think she's
in her 60s i think she's going to be in
her 70s maybe and so she's probably like
what do i care i can burn the place down
on my way out and get what i want and
some people have pointed out that there
was some like i don't want to get too
much into it but some exchanges were
made let's just put it that way some say
there was some monetary movement in some
capacity that i'm not super familiar
with i'm not going to get into but she
probably cut a deal in my opinion they
came to her and said
look
you're not up for re-election until
2026. your voters are dumb as box of
rocks so they're going to completely
forget that's that's how they think
that's that's what they think of you
by the time you're up for re-election
this will be a non-issue
so give it to us now we'll give you
these things and who cares anyway and
then they probably all pop the champagne
started laughing and spitting on
pictures of their constituents
i despise these people yeah that's not
obvious
but good
i know i think there is something to
what you're saying about putting these
people on blast regularly it's important
for your audience to hear especially
members of your audience who live in the
area who actually is interested in
representing their interests and who
will bend at the last moment it's very
disappointing that there were any
republicans who are willing to sign on
to this unfortunately some of them were
and i think we do have a duty to
criticize them it's it's also about
making contact you can criticize them in
the background but they're going to
ignore it unless you actually call the
office because it's that time it's the
time is more valuable than the money
didn't uh didn't chuck schumer say it
was okay to protest at the home of
senators he did that's insane yeah he
did say that i believe so yeah so so
it's okay chuck schumer chuck schumer
was wrong if he said that why why is it
wrong well he said it i mean i think as
far as i know it's illegal no it's not
it's illegal to protest protest in front
of the home of a judge or a member of
the court but that's not getting
enforced either right so maybe the only
thing these people will answer to is an
actual anger group of protesters being
like
you know what i'll put it this way the
left they do these things it works for
him republicans keep dropping to their
knees maybe it's about time some younger
libertarian moderate conservative
whatever you want to call it started
saying okay we can play the game as well
yeah the united states
is an angry group of protesters that was
what we were when we started we still
are the united states is a protest a
wise man told me that one time it sounds
a lot like mob rule though you know you
just get the the mob with the pitchforks
yeah running the show and whoever has
the the bigger mob and there's the
conundrum that's why we have a
representative
the the cultural right which has
expanded quite dramatically thanks to
the left um now incorporates post
liberals along with moderates and
conservatives as they continually just
say no no we don't do that here and the
left is like you got it buddy we do
then republicans keep just saying it's
it's a simple equation i'll give it to
you in terms of why twitter likes
censorship
twitter like censorship for one reason
they have a lot of employees who are
very much in a censorship but there's
also the fact that
do you think dave rubin is going to lead
a group of classical liberals with
pitchforks and bricks and molotov
cocktails to twitter hq and they're all
glad the violence i agree we disagree
with you we disagree
do you think do you think dave rubin
would ever lead a violent mob to that
quarters of twitter
i don't know about that probably not his
style yeah he definitely wouldn't know
his do you think antifa would
absolutely force the whole thing and so
when you have a dude literally trying to
kill a sitting supreme court justice and
people illegally protesting at the homes
of justices the politicians know exactly
who they're afraid of they're terrified
of the left and the right wing is a
bunch of spineless cowards that they can
ignore because the right's always just
like well you know hold on there a
minute i remember back in like 2016 i
was out in front of trump tower in new
york and there was a bunch of people
protesting and there was one dude
leaning leaning up against the wall
we were talking he asked some questions
because we were like journalists
covering the event and i was like you
know what what do you think you support
trump he's like oh yeah definitely and
then i was like so why don't you start
saying you support trump no no no i
don't want anyone to know i was like
okay dude secret trump voters
congratulations yeah but don't you see
like with the school board uh meetings
the pushback from parents the pushback
on disney a lot of this stuff like don't
you see the right getting a little fired
up and the parents in loudoun county are
going to wait around a little bit more
the parents the parents in loudoun and a
lot of these parents that are speaking
up aren't conservatives they're just
regular people who are not doing it for
political reasons yeah we were talking
last night about how the right is really
everybody that's not being crushed into
this cult by the mass media yeah
and the way you framed it like the
teachers right the people the student
i'm sorry the parents rising up the the
immediate assumption is that must be the
right that's that's how the media frames
it when you go and talk to these people
like i don't know anything about that
loudoun county is like a suburb of dc
you know it's like a minute away from
here this is like a mixed very liberal
area these people are getting angry so
you take a look at uh you know i can put
it this way
twitter facebook youtube purged all of
the conservatives who are talking about
standing up and protesting
laura loomer chaining herself to twitter
hq oh they they ban her alex jones they
say those metaphors don't fly then you
get protesters outright breaking the law
and genseki encouraging him to do it and
you know social media companies like
yeah it's fine so what they don't have
to worry about they don't have to worry
about conservatives they have to worry
about parents
it's parents because parents it's not
political it's about their kids they
turned parents into a voting block
exactly which is crazy unbelievable yeah
they don't understand it's so funny
they'll um
you know they'll talk about like how
terrified they feel and how scared they
are of the right it's like all right if
you're scared of someone you don't start
screwing with their kids yeah it's so
obviously phony what can we do you know
i was so i've been doing uh we we got a
billboard in times square which was like
it was meant to be like a big statement
like we've arrived like we are now in
the space and that now a whole bunch of
other organizations like you know the
daily wire had the time square billboard
for us we worked together on one parlor
bought uh the same digital space that we
did
and uh i'm also looking at like what's
the best way we've never spent any money
on marketing
and so one of the things we came up with
was direct marketing is a bad idea
what's a good idea is culture jamming as
marketing so what we did in times square
was partly that some of the best
marketing was just calling out taylor
lorenz for being a liar that worked
really well for us and and the daily
wire
and so i'm wondering like
can i just how much would it cost to buy
every billboard in town of 50 000. i'd
imagine it'd be like 20 grand you know
for a month because it's a small very
small city so okay what if we just
we just do that we just start
crowdfunding we start just taking major
cultural actions to make bold statements
and just
dominate the conversation set the news
cycle
yeah let's do it and it also enhances
local economies that's a good idea do
people pay a lot of attention to
billboards when every billboard in your
town is the same one ragging on your
your local politician i think people
will notice tim is going to put a
billboard outside of a supreme court
justice's house he's going to put a
billboard a tim cass billboard on a
billboard you don't have to be hot
so during the lockdowns
i went to a sushi restaurant
and
they
nobody was wearing masks
we walk in the front door and we're
standing next to the like the host
podium or whatever and they're like put
a mask on and then i was like i was like
nobody's wearing masks and they're like
but you have to wear a mask and i was
like now hold on there a minute like
nobody in the restaurant is wearing a
mask and they're like they're eating and
i was like
we're planning on eating too and they're
like no you have to wear a mask now and
then i was like if i sit down in that
table five feet from me can i not wear
the mask and they were like yes but put
the mask on now and then i was like are
you serious and then all of the
employees go yes and i'm like dude i am
done with this
and i was like you know what i could do
i could hire someone to fly a sign in
front of their restaurant
or like offer coupons to a rival sushi
restaurant across the street or
something
why not why not actually do culture
jamming to make a statement against
those who don't believe in freedom who
are too cowardly or these politicians
how about i hire
50 people to fly signs all throughout
charleston west virginia that just are
dancing with signs saying that shelley
uh capital is trash just that make sure
everybody knows there's disdain for this
person there's value to dogging on your
opponent there's also value to enhancing
the people you believe in so i think
both are effective you know the funny
thing is
someone tweeted at me that
as an individual you can spend as much
money as you want in any kind of
political statement and that there are
some limits but if you're doing it as
educational in fact it could be even tax
deductible or something and i'm like i
don't know about all that like i'll just
talk to my lawyer and be like what am i
allowed to do in terms of ragging on
rhinos because uh i think it would be
excellent marketing for tim cast and the
podcast to make like an ad that's like
come watch our podcast and this
politician is a piece of garbage
i think it'd be great advertising you
know but that is political so certain
billboards won't run it because it's
political
maybe if i just say the person's name is
garbage then it's a free speech thing
like we were we were able to say taylor
lorenz is a liar
or no no
i think we said taylor lauren's doc's
libs of tick tock that's what it was and
the the the
time square billboards like that's fine
yeah
as long as we weren't advertising a
product
we're just making a statement part of it
is i think uh a good thing for you
personally to do is to stay cool stay
calm and organized
it's a vague like like where's the
where's the call to action in it and it
might not be for you that might be for
i'm speaking to myself because you're
very good with fire and uh you know
aggression and stuff like that
um but i think it's the long game it's
gonna be a 50-year 100-year they need
you calm and
able to see the big picture i'm just
taught you know what i'm really bored
with
it's like
everything's just so routine and yeah
and the same thing exactly the left
comes out there's a double standard
imagine if we did this yeah and then
exactly the same thing over and over
again and i'm like won't someone please
throw a figurative pie the name the name
calling falls into that though with the
it's it's boring it's repetitive you
know everyone's a racist everyone's a
bigot everyone who disagrees with you is
disinformation you know
yeah
hate speech hate speech but that's you
know it's just so repetitive it's
monotonous it's a fun house it loses its
effectiveness when it's just
it's applied to everybody that you
disagree with it's true let's put a
funhouse mirror in front of these
people's faces yeah i saw um
a while ago and this is something we all
see frequently but someone posted an
article on twitter about the racist
origins of blank and they said look this
is really interesting articles like how
could any article calling something
racist be interesting at this point
right how could you possibly read them
like wow what an original thought you
called something you didn't like racist
seth does that still get clicks yeah
good questions give me a random noun
uh a person placer thing random noun
random
make it a good oh that one's too obvious
get a little bit more obscure dog
that was my first one
okay i'm gonna put this way i gotta go
i'm going to search for a noun is racist
yeah
why is my dog racist can dogs be racist
can dogs be racist what to do if your
dog seems racist can dogs be racist what
i think their dog is racist my dog is
racist
dogs are racist i'm sure you'll see some
article about gentrification
i remember the article before yeah i
remember the article
what it's the same thing ask amy i think
their dog is racist i looked up amygdala
the effects of skin tone on race-related
amygdala activity wow i mean maybe maybe
it's like that's that's houses are
genetically realistic well this one's
easy
of course they are yeah
yep i mean that one's obvious
give me a good nap
computer oh come on that one's too
obvious no no it's not that obvious
computers are racist sour patch kids
when computers are racist rise of the
racist robots master enslave the fight
over offensive terms can computers be
racist come on these are green news
guard certified artificial intelligence
is racist even ai is racist computer
programmers about mugs and sex mods
let's try mugs are racists yeah
eyeglasses mugs are racist
racist oh not selling these stuff
there you go
amazon racist coffee so the thing is we
did learn that there are indeed racist
mugs it turns out you can buy it racist
zazzle no like this one's all selling
no i know that's racism with a message
racism 101 mugs cocktails and statues
bro i'm telling you you can get this
one's funny because the entire search is
like they're trying to sell you racist
but there was one market for it there's
one article talking about mugs cocktails
and statues racism 101. okay i got a
good noun for you racism racism
let's find out
probably not won't be able to find it i
mean i was told love is love so racism
might be racist i mean is that really a
thing though racism i don't know i mean
the problem there is that i don't think
google search can accurately understand
what that gotcha can't deal with
tautologies yeah uh flags are racist
what about yes
are you racist
uh confederate battle flag how americans
feel about the u.s flag why is the
confederate flag racist of course that's
the most time of the confederate let's
do this let's do minus confederate minus
confederate nice well that one he's
using google
there we go
american flag flyers are racist
yeah remember the flags on trucks
journalists are freaking out he's just
it's all racist
mowing your lawn is late racist i saw an
article about that
your lawn is do any landscaping at all
it's privileged super racist better to
have tall grass
manicured longs are racist
i'm trying to find
though he could be joking he's
definitely yeah but i'm not sure if he's
actually referencing anything in that
joke as well i think i think ryan long
did this bit where he was like
you know how to write an article and
then he was like just what was it he was
like pulling nouns and adjectives out of
a hat yeah why blank is blank and then
he showed all the articles that actually
existed
that was just absolutely insane
the dogs being racist one is actually
was a big deal
because a bunch of people were pointing
out that they were saying
dogs are a sign of gentrification and
dogs themselves are racist because they
like bark at you know minorities or
something like that well and so in a
weird way this is obviously a sign of
cultural decay but there's also
something here about the bubble that's
existed within the new media landscape
so you've talked about this before but
basically you had a lot of venture
capitalists investing in blog type
websites and news sites so these
companies were way overvalued they hired
a bunch of people to write articles
there's only so many things you can
write articles about so eventually you
just got a bunch of stuff about racism
and the market became oversaturated with
stuff that no one was really reading
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and we'll see you all
there